qu'est ce qui menace la démocratie de
disparition ça c'est la grosse question
alors la première menace pour la
démocratie au 21e siècle c'est moi les
périls extérieur la chine et son total
capitalisme où les démocrates eurent
veut même le djihadisme que en réalité
sa corruption intérieur sa corruption
intérieur par la démagogie et les
conséquences de la décomposition des
classes moyennes les démocraties ont
subi des chocs terribles le krach de
ensuite les vagues d'attentats
terroristes maintenant l'épidémie de
deux copines et c'est vrai qu'elles
doivent trouver en elle-même la manière
de se réformer pour faire face à ces
chocs qu'elles doivent aussi trouver la
manière de se réunir et de former à
nouveau une alliance des nations libres
pour défendre leurs principes et leurs
malheurs dans cette histoire qui est
maintenant une histoire univers